>>> OVERNIGHT THE UKRAINIAN AIR
FORCE SAYS IT INTERCEPTED 23 OF
THE 25 RUSSIAN CRUISE MISSILES
LAUNCHED THEIR WAY, 15 TARGETED
THE CAPITAL OF KYIV.
THIS VIDEO YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT
HERE SHOWS THE SMOKE TRAILS FROM
THE EXPLOSIONS OVER THE CITY AT
DAWN.
IT IS THE FIFTH HEAVY ASSAULT ON
KYIV THIS MONTH AND THERE WAS A
CNN TEAM JUST 700 YARDS FROM
WHERE ONE MISSILE LANDED IN
SOUTHEAST UKRAINE.
WATCH THIS.
THAT WAS CNN'S NICK PATON
WALSH'S TEAM.
HE JOINS US NOW FROM
ZAPORIZHZHIA.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
I WANT TO SHOW FOLKS ALSO --
SHOW WHAT YOU SHOWED US LATER
WAS YOU ACTUALLY STOOD IN THE
CRATER OF THAT BLAST OF WHAT WAS
CREATED AND WHAT WAS LEFT OVER
FROM THAT EXPLOSION.
THAT'S ENORMOUS, THE KIND OF
DESTRUCTION.
JUST A REMINDER YET AGAIN OF THE
DESTRUCTION THAT THESE MISSILES
LEAVE BEHIND.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING AND
LEARNING ABOUT THE STRIKE, THE
TARGET AND WHAT PEOPLE THERE ARE
PREPARING FOR NOW?
>> Reporter: YEAH, LOOK, I MEAN,
WHAT YOU ARE REFERRING TO THERE
IS A TOWN WHICH HAS BEEN MAULED
FRANKLY BY RUSSIAN AIR STRIKES
AND ARTILLERY FOR I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THE LAST MONTH OR SO
IT IS ON THE FRONT LINE ON THE
SOUTHERN FRONT WHERE MANY EXPECT
UKRAINE'S COUNTEROFFENSIVE TO
PUT MOST OF ITS ENERGY.
WHAT STARTLED US OVER A NUMBER
OF DAYS THERE WAS THE
INDISCRIMINATE NATURE.
YES, YOU COULD POSSIBLY THINK
THERE MIGHT BE MILITARY TARGETS
AROUND, WE CAN'T DISCUSS THEM IN
DETAIL DUE TO REPORTING
RESTRICTIONS BUT OFTEN THESE
STRIKES MISS WILDLY AND THE
MISSILE THAT FLEW OVER OUR HEADS
COST HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
ACCORDING TO SOME WESTERN
ESTIMATES.
THESE ARE NOT THINGS TO
NECESSARILY BE TRIFLED WITH OR
USED LIB REA
ERALLY BUT THEY AD
ALONG THAT FRONT LINE.
THIS IS A SIGN I THINK OF RUSSIA
BEGINNING TO EXPRESS ITS RANGE,
ITS BID TO HOLD UKRAINE BACK.
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW EFFECTIVE IT'S
NECESSARILY GOING TO BE.
WE DID SEE OURSELVES BLACK SMOKE
FURTHER ON THE HORIZON THAT
SUGGESTED A KEY OBJECTIVE FOR
UKRAINE, A TOWN MIGHT BE BEING
HIT QUITE HARD.
THIS IS ALL PART OF THE GENERAL
SENSE THAT WE MAY BE SEEING THE
OPENING STAGES OF THE
COUNTEROFFENSIVE GETTING UNDER
WAY.
RUSSIA CONTINUES TO LAUNCH
BARRAGES OF DRONES AND MISSILES
NIGHTLY FRANKLY FOR THE PAST
WEEK ACROSS ALL OF UKRAINE,
STARTLING THE VOLUME THEY'RE
SENDING.
WHAT'S MORE STARTLING FRANKLY IS
THE EFFECTIVENESS SO FAR OF
UKRAINIAN AIR DEFENSES.
YOU MENTIONED HOW ALL 15 CRUISE
MISSILES TARGETING THE CAPITAL
WERE INTERCEPTED ACCORDING TO
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS AND ONLY TWO
GOT THROUGH ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE'VE SEEN INTERMITTENT AWFUL
MOMENTS WHERE SOME OF THESE
MISSILES HAVE GOT THROUGH, YOU
KNOW, IN KHERSON, SOME SHELLING
GOT THROUGH LAST WEEK, BUT THE
BROADER STORY IS THAT RUSSIA'S
BARRAGES ARE NOT REALLY THAT
EFFECTIVE BECAUSE OF UKRAINE'S
IMPROVED AIR DEFENSES.
A SECONDARY STORY TO ALL OF THIS
NOW IS WE BEGIN TO SEE THE
TENSION AROUND THIS
COUNTEROFFENSIVE BUILDING IS THE
EXTRAORDINARY DISUNITY OF
RUSSIA'S MESSAGING AT THE
MOMENT.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE VICTORY
DAY PARADES IN MOSCOW SHRUNKEN,
AT THE SAME TIME, AT THE SAME
TIME HE HAVE G EVGENI PRIGOZHINS
NOT CLEAR WHAT HE'S NECESSARILY
GOING TO DO THERE.
REAL MOSCOW DISCOUNTY ON A DAY
THEY'RE TRYING TO PROJECT UNITY
AND STRENGTH.
A LOT WRONG IN THE HOUSE OF
RUSSIA.
>> NO KIDDING.
GREAT TO SEE YOU AND YOUR TEAM
CONTINUE TO BE SAFE.
SARA?
>>> JOINING US TO DISCUSS IS
LIEUTENANT GENERAL MARK
HERTLING.
I LOVE TALKING TO YOU IN THE
MORNING BECAUSE YOU GIVE SUCH
GOOD ANALYSIS.
I WANT TO ASK YOU FIRST ABOUT
RUSSIA, WHICH HAS SCALED BACK
ITS VICTORY DAY, WHICH WOULDN'T
SEEM LIKE A BIG DEAL EXCEPT THEY
HAVE HAD SOMEONE, WE DON'T KNOW
WHO, HAD A DRONE HIT THE KREMLIN
AND THEN OF COURSE YOU HAVE THIS
WAR GOING ON IN THE BACKGROUND.
THEY TRIED TO TELL THEIR
CITIZENS WASN'T A WAR AT FIRST,
IT WAS EVEN ILLEGAL TO SAY THE
WORD.
SO WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU THIS
DISPLAY WHERE THERE'S JUST A
SINGLE TANK ON THE GROND AND
THEN YOU SEE THE YOUNG SOLDIERS
THERE AS WELL?
>> SARA, IT'S GREAT TO TALK TO
YOU, TOO.
WHEN I WOKE UP TO THE PICTURES
OF THE MAY DAY PARADE I WAS JUST
APPALLED.
I MEAN, IT WAS FASCINATING TO
SEE WHAT LITTLE THEY WERE DOING
IN A PARADE THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
CAPTURE THE IMAGINATION AND THE
HERITAGE OF THE OLD SOVIET
UNION.
IT WAS -- I MEAN, IT WAS JUST
LAUGHABLE TO HAVE ONE TANK WITH
A SOVIET FLAG.
THEY DID HAVE OTHER VEHICLES,
BUT THEY WERE OLD, THEY WERE
TRUCKS, THERE WEREN'T ANY COMBAT
EQUIPMENT IN THERE OTHER THAN
THEIR LAUNCHERS FOR SOME OF
THEIR BALLISTIC MISSILES.
IT JUST GIVES AN INDICATOR OF
HOW MUCH TROUBLE RUSSIA IS IN.
NICK PEYTATON WALSH'S COMMENTAR
ABOUT THE MISSILES THAT ARE
CONTINUING TO MISS THE MARK, TO
GO INTO CITIES WHERE THEY'RE
HITTING BUILDINGS THAT CIVILIANS
LIVE IN, BUT NOT DOING ANY --
HAVING ANY KIND OF MILITARY
EFFECT REALLY IS A COMMENTARY ON
A LACK OF SOMETHING WE IN THE
MILITARY CALL PRECISE TARGETING.
ARTILLERYMEN AND MISSILEERS WORK
TO GET THEIR MISSILES ON A
SPECIFIC TARGET AND IT SEEMS
LIKE RUSSIA IS FIRING THESE
ARBITRARILY AT DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS.
VERY FACT THAT NICK WAS STANDING
IN A HOLE THAT WAS NOWHERE NEAR
ANY TARGET TELLS ME EVERYTHING I
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT HOW POOR THE
RUSSIANS ARE STILL CONDUCTING
THIS CAMPAIGN.
>> YEAH, OF COURSE, SOME WOULD
ARGUE THAT THEY ARE PURPOSELY
HITTING SOME AREAS WHERE
CIVILIANS ARE.
I DO WANT TO MENTION SOMETHING
THAT YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT,
UKRAINE'S MILITARY SAYS IT
INTERCEPTED 23 OF 25 RUSSIAN
CRUISE MISSILES.
SO, AGAIN, TO YOUR POINT, THEY
ARE ABLE TO SORT OF THWART SOME
OF THE ATTACKS.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE PARADE
AND SOMETHING THAT WE HEARD FROM
THE HEAD OF RUSSIA'S WAGNER
MERCENARY FORCE.
FIRST THAT FORCE THREATENED TO
STOP FIGHTING, TO PULL ITS
FIGHTERS BACK BECAUSE THERE WAS
NOT ENOUGH AMMUNITION.
SO TELLS YOU A LITTLE SOMETHING
ABOUT WHERE THEY ARE.
AND NOW THE HEAD OF THAT FORCE
IS CRITICIZING THE KREMLIN FOR
EVEN HAVING THIS PARADE.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID.
HE SAID VICTORY DAY IS THE
VICTORY OF OUR GRANDFATHERS.
THIS IS THE PART THAT REALLY
GETS YOU.
WE HAVEN'T EARNED THAT VICTORY
ONE MILLIMETER.
DOES THAT REALLY TELL YOU WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN UKRAINE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME?
>> YOU KNOW, SHARE RATION I'VE
BEEN FOLLOWING THE DRAMA THAT'S
EXISTED BETWEEN PRIGOZHIN,
SHOIGU WHO IS THE DEFENSE
MINISTRY OF RUSSIA, GRASS MOVE
WHO IS THE EQUIVALENT OF THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS AND
PUTIN.
THIS HAS BEEN POLITICAL INTRIGUE
INSIDE OF THE KREMLIN THAT'S
BURST OUT INTO THE OPEN.
THE RUSSIANS ARE SEEING THIS,
THE WORLD IS SEEING THIS,
THERE'S THIS INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS
NO MILITARY BACKGROUND, THAT'S
PRIGOZHIN, HE IS NOT A SOLDIER,
HE KNOWS VERY LITTLE ABOUT
SOLDERING, JUST THROWING MEAT AT
THE UKRAINIANS AND KILLING A LOT
OF RUSSIANS AND THEN PROCLAIMING
THAT HE'S NOT GETTING SUPPORT.
IT'S JUST AMAZING TO ME A LACK
OF PROFESSIONALISM AND THE FACT
THAT RUSSIAN GENERALS WHO AREN'T
VERY GOOD BY MY ASSESSMENT BASED
ON PERSONAL CONVERSATIONS AND
ALSO WHAT I'M WATCHING ARE
ALLOWING THIS TO HAPPEN AND THAT
MR. PUTIN IS USING THIS AS A
STRATEGY TO STOKE THINGS INSIDE
THE KREMLIN.